jen
is with us in orange county california
hi jen
welcome to the show how can we help
hi uh mr ramsay and dr delany thank you
so much for taking my call
sure um my husband have a
life household money question for you um
we have a couple different options for
me potentially starting to work
part-time that we're considering and
we wanted to get your opinion if we've
considered all of our options and what
is the best way to maybe test those
options
we are on baby steps four five and six
and we're both working right now
um and we love our careers but more
recently i just felt a tug to want to be
at home more um we have two kids
a five-year-old and a two-year-old and
we've also realized that how much
work there is for managing a house and
the cooking and the laundry and
appointments
and so the the two options we're really
looking at is
is me going part-time when the
five-year-old goes to school next fall
and we can still pay off the house in
in a little less than 15 years if we do
that
um the other option we're looking at
because we really want
the freedom and getting the house paid
off is is to suck it up for like
three years and pay off the house um
because then i wouldn't really have it
um have to have the option to work maybe
um but that would mean maybe doing more
of a baby step 3b
four-ish and bringing the retirement
down to maybe the company match
so those are the two options we're
considering what do you make
um together we make it no no no what do
you make
165. you make 165.
what does he make about 135.
what does he do um he's in finance for a
local restaurant company
and how old are you guys we're 37.
okay what do you do um i'm
work for medical device company
regulatory
and you can do that part-time um
i think i have options even if the
company
i don't i work at currently wouldn't be
willing to do it i think i
i know enough people in industry um or
could potentially
consult if if that company or another
company wouldn't
wouldn't harm me but i'm okay so if you
went part-time how much does it cut your
all's income
you're from 165 to what one about 80.
so about in half yep okay
if i'm in your shoes i'm going part-time
in september when the five-year-old goes
to school
okay the way i decided that was this is
not a question
of financial well-being
this is just a question of how fast you
get rich
yeah you cannot have those years back
yeah i'll trade i'll trade getting rich
a little slower
for you to be there with the
five-year-old when she comes home making
her cookies
or whatever the scenario is you want to
do yeah
yeah that's quality of life hard to hear
that okay
it's quality of life well the thing is
you you get tremendous satisfaction and
you're tremendously good
at your job you don't hate your job no
no you're a professional woman i mean
you are you're killing it
and so you're really trading something
that you
love for something that you love more
and jen you need to know and like i'm
telling you like you don't know this
there is an entire industry there's an
entire
cultural ethos that is against women
having peace
period so if you're at work
crushing it at 165 you and your husband
are just
sailing through life there is a part of
that culture that's gonna
tug on you and say why aren't you at
home they're going to shame you for not
being a mom
yeah and you're going to yeah then
you're going to take
you're going to take a a a half pay cut
still making double the average u.s
salary
you're going to go home and there's
going to be an industry telling you
seriously what kind of what kind of
modern woman are you you walked away
from that career what's wrong with you
you're just going to you hate your
family financially so there's a [ __ ]
out there somewhere to shame you no
matter what you do
right and so here's what you have to do
as you make this transition and i'm
speaking from somebody we've made the
same transition in our
my house okay you got to get a couple of
people around you
that are going to be able to walk
alongside you as you make this
transition you're going to have to learn
new skills and
most of us don't think i have to learn
skills on how to run a household i can
just quote unquote take care of my kids
it's more complex than that you got to
learn some new things and you got to
have people around you that you can
reach out to and say
today sucks and i love my kids but i
don't like them today
and that aren't going to judge you and
say you're the worst mom and we're going
to send you mean cards and pray for you
but they're going to laugh and send you
funny memes and you're going to go on
with your day
and then there's going to be people who
are going to pick you up on the work
side of it
and and and but you gotta have folks who
walk alongside you i just
dave i know too many folks who go home
to follow this call to be at home with
their kids
and then it just is a silent vortex
there and they get lonely and they start
doubting and then they start looking
online and then everybody's telling them
what a loser they are and they made the
wrong decision
and it's hard you gotta have people walk
alongside you when you do this this
is this is when you learn that
facebook friends are not friends you're
not your friends
no no they're not real
they're not they're not real friends
they're not oh my gosh yeah
jen go home go home and it's going to be
hard and used
to use that wonderful brain that god
gave you to be a world-class mom while
you're doing consulting or whatever it
is you
and here's the other thing you've done
all of your projections
as if your income is linear and his
income is linear and it's not you're
both in professional careers both of you
are going to see your incomes go up even
if you're working part-time
and he's continuing to so it's not a
15-year versus a three-year
it's a three-year versus a uh eight or
ten year
yeah you're gonna get there good for you
really really good question